hello everyone uh today is a special day
i'm here as you can see not alone not by
myself as usual i'm joined by martin
schmid who is the first author of the
paper called player of games this is
joint work with others by deep mind and
i have to say it's it's a very
in-depth paper uh it presents an
algorithm called player of games that is
sort of a unified algorithm to play all
sorts of games this starts at things
like chess and go which you might know
from alpha zero
but it goes beyond it goes to things
like poker and
scotland yard which i found really
interesting that it appears here but
sort of the common denominator
is that these new games they have hidden
information so other than chess or go
in scotland yard you don't know where mr
x is hiding in poker you have no clue
what cards the other players hold so you
can't just look
at like the table and poker and decide
what's the best thing to do because
you don't know a lot of things and yeah
same in scotland yard there have been
there have been algorithms for poker
right there have been algorithms for
scotland the art but they were always a
bit tailored to sort of the specifics of
the games
and player of games combines a large set
of techniques and and these techniques
are things like let's to search so as we
play the game we do local search we sort
of invest some computation at inference
time to tell us what the best possible
move is but we don't want to search
throughout all the game because these
game trees they just get very big so
that's the part that comes in from alpha
zero a little bit but then the other
part with the unknown information that
is
coming in mostly from the from
algorithms like counterfactual regret
minimization and so on um but
yeah the counterfactual regret
minimization if i understand these
correctly they were sort of solvers like
they either solved a complete game or
they didn't right you'd have to like
traverse the whole game and then at the
end you knew okay in this situation i
need to do this and so on and yeah this
i i was very excited when i saw this
paper and then i tried to read it and it
was it was it was i have to say it was
dense and i'm very happy to have martin
here today uh to guide us a little bit
through the paper
so martin welcome uh thank you very much
for being here
hey i'm happy to be here
um did was was it a sort of a good
description of what i said so far about
player of games
oh yes very very very much so
if you if you could if you could
summarize sort of the the main
components of this algorithm this is a
single algorithm that i can train on
many many games what are what is the set
of games i can train it on
so the the currently we use we use four
games the the games that you mentioned
we have we have chess we have go we have
scotland which i find uh as as a very
cool and fun fun game and we have uh we
have no random poker so that it's just
to show the generality of it because
this is all i'm all about uh all about
the generality that's why we picked like
two perfect and two imperfect
information games yeah so currently it
should be able to handle
handle most perfect and imperfect
information games as it planned so from
scratch from self play just so like
alpha alpha 0 does there are some some
some limitations so for games that this
this can handle and we can uh it's it's
best to understand the limitations only
after we understand a bit more about the
algorithm itself yeah so the the
algorithm itself is composed of many
parts but the the central concepts here
i think are and that's what people i
think people
kind of know what alpha zero does right
it uses self play and it searches
it searches a game tree to a certain
depth right so so it in these games we
usually have like some sort of a state
right and then we have various different
actions that we could take in that state
and every action leads to a next state
and so on and we have various different
actions we could take right here and
every action leads to a next state and
you can quickly see how this explodes
right so what what alpha zero and all
these search algorithms do they do this
kind of limited depth search right they
they look maybe one or two moves ahead
but at some point they say okay no
further um we can't afford to compute
all of this three and that's why at a
certain depth or after a certain time
they say okay here we cut off and we use
like a neural network to tell us how
good this node is even though we're not
at the end of the game
where we would either win or lose we
could still have a neural network that
sort of predicts
this node is is very good for you or
this node is very bad for you and that's
that's essentially alpha alpha zero in a
nutshell let's say uses self play uses
this tree search at a certain depth it
simply asks the neural network
now what's the what's the problem
when you have imperfect information how
does how does this change
okay i know that's that's
that's the that's the right question
unfortunately we we it we probably spent
quite some time to to understand the uh
the intuition of it right but even for
for alpha zero it's uh it's good to step
back and see where it came from right
it's not it's not that alpha zero
introduced the search for say perfect in
information games right that search has
been here say since 1950s like first
first algorithm algorithms for chess did
combination of search and some value
functions alpha zeros is amazing in the
sense that it blends those value
functions that that you just described
through through soft by software and
it's also really really smart about how
it's going to to expand it's a it's such
surgery it's not like it's going to
always look two steps steps ahead it's
it's very smart about burden building
this tree that goes deeper where they
need to need it to to go deeper yeah but
it still yes has those components which
uh these components are simply having
some search tree that it ideally expands
as it's print about a policy in the
search tree and then using some value
function id at the end of the search
tree
yeah that is that is one of the one of
the hallmarks of of alpha zero i think
that for example in go you have so many
actions even at step one right uh if you
were to consider only like even three
steps ahead or so this would just blow
your computation budget but in alpha
zero it sort of it sort of always starts
from the root and then it kind of goes
down one of these branches that it has
already explored a little bit
and in every new iteration it re-decides
which direction it should investigate
and that's a combination of sort of what
the neural network says but also how
often it's been it's explored something
so it says you know like this direction
i
is very promising but i've explored it a
lot already so now i'll go i'll go a
different branch or so and then at the
end it always goes gets to a leaf node
that it hasn't expanded yet right and at
that point it asks the neural network
okay you know what's what's my policy
here what's my value and then it
prepares sort of the next iteration that
it could expand it even more and so over
time it builds
this very targeted plan
so the neural networks guide the tree
search as you say that's very
very cool now in imperfect information
games that is yeah that is different
right
yeah yes so it's somewhat different but
we still wanted to have exactly what we
just described this is like why alpha 0
works works so so well and we still
wanted it so on high level you can think
of player games as combining
combining alpha zero and uh and dipstick
which if you were to google dipstick
it's it was the it was the first uh ai
to beat the professional players in a no
limit poker and it already introduced
some of the some of the ingredients that
we will see in this paper which is it
introduced this notion of
of local search in in poker and these
value functions and playable games is
really just
putting together alpha zero in deep step
into a single big unified uh algorithm
so the the the let's maybe start with
the with the component that that you
that you just talked about which is
value function
and the value function if if we if we
get to a point where we understand value
function in in player of games
say it's uh
then you understand like 60 to 80
percent of the algorithm and complexity
that imperfect information in perfect
information breaks so value function
if if you think about how to use it uh
exactly as you said rather rather than
searching all the way to the end of the
end of the game because it would be like
way way too long of a search you just uh
trumpet your search and use value
function as a substitute for for
continue to search and
that's that's how you use it but what it
really does it maps some sub problem
that that that you are thinking of
to a game value of that uh sub sub
program or some something in chess or in
go it's really easy to think about what
it really is you get to a new board
chess or go board and the value function
ideally should tell you hey
this is the value of this sub game what
it really means is
what would be the outcome if we if two
optimal players were to continue playing
this game forward right
so that's all the value functions do and
the same thing they do if you try to
generalize them into imperfect
information games except that suddenly
this notion of some game and some
problem gets way more complicated
yeah so it this bases on this this
notion of information states and and
sort of public beliefs about things so
on the left here
you've you've tried to show this in a
diagram and i think the notion is when i
come to a poker table
i only see what's called the public
state right i see
and and um
actually if i come to a poker table and
i observe a hand with all of its history
right that is the public state
um so i know you know who bet how much
in which round and so on who acted how
but i don't see people's cards so there
could be many different cards that
people hold
and
some might be impossible just from the
rules of the game you know maybe not in
poker but you know in scotland yard you
have this over here
there are certain locations this mr x
can be
and
we want to assign probabilities to each
one of them right if we knew
if we knew where mr x was the game would
be easy right but since we don't know
um we must estimate and i think that's
also something you highlight in the
paper an interesting property of these
games is that
if i am mr x or if i play poker
i have to
not be deterministic
right otherwise the game would be very
easy for my opponents if that's in poker
usually you know people they look at
their cards they go
and then they like bet everything they
have and
you know you immediately know
which hand they have if they don't also
do the same thing with other uh other
hole cards or if they don't randomize a
bit so necessarily other than
let's say in chess the optimal strategy
is kind of a distribution over actions
uh and you have to sort of randomize
that in order to almost a bit hide your
your your private state
so
what we what we see are these public
states right um
and
what we can estimate is these things
which are called the ranges so these are
distributions
over
what private states the players could
hold right
and
the
i think the difficulty in this tree
search comes from the fact that you can
only go from a public state
yet you need to consider
all the possibilities of the private
states so you can't just say this is the
situation you have to sort of consider
all of them at the same time right
yes exactly that's that's what you
basically need in order to generalize
those sub games or sub programs to
imperfect information right it's not
hard to hard to see that all perfect
information games are just a special
case where you have just a single single
possible state for for for for the
player right like the poker you just
talk about poker and public state states
and that's a that's a that's a perfect
example right like the sub program in
poker
it it makes a little to no sense to say
what's a value
what's the value of a sub game or sub
problem in a poker where where i hold
the pair of asics that's pretty much
ill-defined to your defined subject
but what we what you need to do is given
a given a public state which is as you
say i come to a table i see everything
that i could have observed as a public
observer so that's that that's basically
my state but given this state given this
observation
there's a lot of possible individual
individual states of the of the game
that are consistent with this
observation and they these simply
correspond to all the different cards
the the players could be holding
and sub game is simply defined by by
combination of this public state which
is the thing i get to observe as a
public observer and a distribution over
all the possible private states that
could be happening right now and given
this distribution on top this simply
defines a well-defined sub game and
given this well-defined subgame i can
suddenly ask questions of well what
would what would be the values of this
sub problem given that they all the
agents play the sub game optimally just
just as i do in chester ago
yeah i we used to we used to play poker
a lot in like high school and this was
frequently you you try to you not try to
guess what hands your opponent have but
you try to guess you know what their
range is right
so you consider like okay it's often
going to be these cards it's less often
going to be these cards i think that
mirrors very much the reasoning that
that people actually have in these
things and
now given given this you
at the one of the core things here is
this neural network that is supposed to
uh tell us what the values of the sub
game is right
and this as you said it gets as an input
description of the public state and it
also gets as an input your beliefs about
what distribute like your beliefs about
the ranges of the players so what their
private information could be and how
often and if i remember correctly these
rangers they're just a result of their
strategies right if you know the
strategies of the players then you can
calculate what their ranges are because
if the strategy is i always bet high
when i have aces then
if the player bet high then aces are
quite likely you put all of this into a
neural network and the neural network
gives you
uh policies which is understandable it's
how would a player act in a given
situation this is also what alpha zero
gives you but then you have these
counterfactual values
and this is a bit of a new term that
only appears in
i think in imperfect information games
what is a counterfactual value
right so in this case this value
function very much is analogous to alpha
0 in the sense that you have
values and policy or policy for a sub
game and we use we use them in very
similar way except as as we just
described a sub game uh is uh
there's many possible states the game
the game or the players could be in
given given a public public state
subgame or public subject and to value
function given this subgame outputs not
just a single value that says hey value
of the star game is 5 it actually
outputs a single value for all the
possible player states that are possible
given the sub game so in poker say i
could be holding 1000 different hand
combinations in the in
the holden poker so the network will
tell me hey in this sub game if you were
to hold this particular pair of hands
this is the value and it will it will
tell me such value for all the possible
states i could be in yeah okay and did
the neural network
how how is it built to
output um does it have like one
let's say one output head
so does it output like a thousand
dimensional vector one entry for each
okay
so is it is it fair to say that your
algorithm would struggle with um games
where the possible
private states are
huge
that's yeah that the the this this is
brilliant this is exactly why i say it
it will be nicer to understand the
limitations once we get a bit deeper
into the algorithm and this is exactly
the the main limitation that we
currently have because in some games
this just explodes yeah i see
okay and you have this network and you
train it uh in some way via self play
and now we get to the part where you
generalize this search procedure right
and
let me see uh this is here so this
search procedure as we said in in alpha
uh again in alpha zero you have
something like
you're at some state in the game right
you've played until this state and what
you do is you do this search and you use
an internal like simulator to do the
search this is at inference time so what
you do is you consider all your actions
you choose on one by given the neural
network's output and
the current search statistics you go
here you ask the neural network well
what's my value here you expand that
node
and then you start again and in the next
iteration you start again from the root
you uh expand maybe the same or maybe
another action it depends but let's say
it's the same right here if it's already
expanded you go further
down the tree and you would you would
sort of you would make many iterations
let's say 50 iterations or something
like this in every iteration you'd go
down the tree and you find a node that
you haven't expanded yet and you'd
expand that node right
in
in in player of games this is quite a
bit more intricate right
as as we also have
many iterations but within each
iteration we have to do a lot more work
in order to actually uh in order to
actually
deal with with this uncertainty so could
you describe a little bit how your
search algorithm works
yes happy too so when we said at the
beginning that playable games is a
hybrid of deep stack and alpha zero
search algorithm is a perfect example of
of this being a hybrid
so what the deep state already
introduced is
it
it had a fixed search tree so you you
are poker player so you
what it really did is it searched all
the way through a single single batting
ground and it used value functions at
the end end of the round and it ran this
kind of actually get minimization which
we might
come back later to but you can think of
it simply some some policy improvement
algorithm given a fixed search it would
iterate and improve the policy and as as
it was walking up and down the tree and
finding a good policy it would use the
value function at the end of the search
the the very same value function that we
just talked about
now player of games uh
adds this now this smart idea of alpha
zero where it also tries to dynamically
expand the search tree rather than
having a fixer tree and the way it does
we simply uh
intertwine two phases where we in one
phase given the sample given some
surgery we try to improve the policy
within the surgery and there's a second
phase where it simply tries to expand
just like alpha zero does using
the same say p u c b b u c b formula we
try to expand the surgery where we think
we need to expand it and then we simply
go back and forth with you like an
expanded tree improve the policy
explanatory improve the policy
yeah so this is built on an algorithm
that you said called counterfactual
regret minimization and this is an this
is if you i were to just apply a
counterfactual regret minimization this
is a solver like i give it a game
description and it just it will expand
the entire game tree every state there
is in the game and it will just sort of
go from node to node in this tree and
improve the policy of both players right
and it just does this for many many
iterations it improves here here here
everywhere in the game tree until the
whole game tree is
approximately optimal
and the the biggest game that has been
solved so far if you describe this in
the paper is limit
limit heads uphold them is that correct
fix them they
yeah that's actually a solved game
yes it it was done a few years ago by
the by the computer pro research group
at the university of alberta led by
michael bowling and it's still
as far as i know the largest game to to
be solved and you used to award solver
which is a perfect perfect name really
and like the way i think about the
solver is you give me some
small or medium-sized game that i can
fit into like a big table on my computer
and by solving it means simply find a
policy for all the possible states in a
game right yeah it's easy to see that
it's like i mean people do know how to
do it in say
the detector or small
small games right and if you were to fit
chess on your computer then again it's
not hard to see that you could just
solve it given the algorithms that
people are familiar with yeah the thing
is even if you have a really really
small improv information game you do
have to use algorithms that that can
handle imperfect information games
often people just use the algorithms
that they like say i don't know like
policy gradient methods uh q learning or
whatever and if you just run it on
imperf information game it just doesn't
find a good policy
yeah i think the i mean intuitively it's
a bit like if i start in some situation
in chess
and i make some moves i have i have
still like that original state is still
the same right i can i can look back i
come from there but if i'm in poker and
i'm in some state and i make some moves
that change is kind of the past right
because i look at you know maybe you're
my my opponent in poker i look at what
you do and that changes my beliefs about
what
you what cards you had back in the past
then i go back and i'm like ah okay you
did this and this so you can't you can't
i don't think you you you're holding you
know a king and an ace given that you've
done something in the future and i think
this
the fact that your future actions change
the past that's what in my opinion makes
this so
much more intriguing and complicated so
on the left side here i think this is
the
this is you have a search a local search
tree right um you it's expanded until
some depth at that depth you ask the
neural network for
you know summarization of whatever
happens below and within that tree you
run now this counter factual regret
minimization or something akin to it and
you simply want to find the best policy
within that tree which is more
complicated in alpha zero i just visit
every node once right because
future doesn't change the past once i
computed a node i only expand things
below it
that never changes that node however in
imperfect information games right if i
change something below
all of a sudden the the path changes so
i need to sort of update and converge
the whole tree
and then once you've done this for a
number of steps on the right side then
you
add a new node by essentially doing what
alpha zero does you go to a leaf node
you choose some action right in some
information state that passes
and uh you perform that action and that
expands actually one more node
is that
you know this is this is excellent and
the the the the property that you just
described that like the future change in
the past that that is also something
that makes search in particular so much
more complicated right because
there's you can figure this out the
two-step process if if you were to just
solve solve some some game you would
just solve it even that is more
complicated because of what you just
described but you could do it there
there's ways to solve solve improve
information games but we are doing
search here and the the the property
that you can talk about makes search so
much more complicated and the reason
being is in imperfect information games
you cannot just glue
or glue together
optimal policies and hope that the
resulting
policy for the full game will be optimal
and that is something that many search
algorithms just rely on and it it simply
holds in perfect information game so if
you were to like
pick any optimal policy in any any any
any state and just put them together
this is and this is an optimal policy in
imperial information games it just it
does not hold because of exactly what we
just described but then how can you even
do search at all if search is all about
like local reasoning right you reason
locally yet you somehow need to make
sure that the resulting policy for the
full game is still optimal
yeah it's it's it's intriguing so
essentially for every step that alpha
zero does where it expands a new node
you also expand a new node but then you
have to like
get the entire tree in order again so
you expand the new node and then you
have to do the whole update of the whole
tree for a bunch of iterations before
you can expand another one such that
everything like stays consistent
yeah okay that's
i mean this this it gives a bit of an
impression of why this is uh much more
much more complex right
yes so this is this is essentially at
inference time we do this search right
um we do the search and now
comes the time when we actually need to
to train this so we have the ingredients
now we have the search algorithm we have
the neural network and now we need to
train it and you also have
you have a method uh or or various
methods um
and maybe you want to describe it
yourself a little bit because
this is the part where i
um stumbled a little so yeah
yeah i would try to do it on very high
level so the idea is again we wanted to
take the self-play style method from
alpha zero so that you just throw the
algorithm into a game and it improves as
as the as the as as it plays and it gets
better and better and what it really
means is you are improving your your
value and
policy right the the network that we
that we just discussed
and
uh the
on high level
since you are using your value function
in your search
you call basically call your neural
network with some inputs some states
public states or some some beliefs
and this
this figure this idea of queries is
simply we call
every single time we call a network we
call this a query we are acquiring a
network for for for some some value over
sub game so we store this tuple of
public state and beliefs and then we go
through all this all those queries and
we simply try to basically improve the
network on the states and the strategies
that the network has been queried
because this is probably what's
important because that's what occurred
during the self play
so you collect the train it's similar to
alpha zero as you say you collect the
training set as you go so the training
set for the next iteration is whatever
the network had to do during this
iteration so it's not just a random
sample of states and
you train
in the same manner as alpha zero you
train to predict your own future outputs
is that approximate so if let's let's
distinguish if
like one or two or three steps in the
future you actually win or lose the game
you can train on your reward of the game
but alpha zero also if it doesn't win or
lose the game in the next step or so it
tries to predict its own output so it
tries to improve that way using td
lambda
you here have a
td1
right
so your your targets what do you target
what do you
give the network as labels
so okay so this is slightly more
complicated here in the sense that
each query basically defines you a
sub-beam right each where it's a public
state and energies and given a sub game
the ideal target for a neural network
would be simply to solve the game right
that's that's that's the ground truth
that that you want your neural network
to to
to to learn or like 10 words too so
rather than solving directly because
again these sub games will still be way
too big as they occur during the
gameplay we do like a small
small solver where we also substitute
the full solver with a small search so
rather than fully solving a game we use
the same method to basically do a search
and the outcome of the search basically
a small solver is what the
what is the target okay so you you do
the same thing yeah you do the same
thing as you do during inference when
you actually want to make a move you
so during that inference you're going to
make some queries to the network you
take these queries and these i think
here are the red dots right exactly so
during
maybe this has battery again so during
the inference you you make you do these
queries you store them in this in this
buffer and these now act as the root
notes for yet another search which is
exactly the same as the previous search
right and so you you sort of rely on the
fact that this search procedure can give
you a better output than the neural
network itself right so yes right
the query here the neural network will
output some value like the value is
eight or one value for each uh for each
information state but you i think the
whole algorithm is and that's of course
the reason we do search in the first
place is that doing search gives you a
better estimate than just using the
neural network at the start so doing
search and then asking the neural
network further down the line gives you
a better estimate and yeah it makes
sense you
start
at wherever you ask the neural network
you use local search to get a better
value doesn't need a perfect one just a
better one and then you train the neural
network to predict the result of the
search
right
that's
that's exactly
one would hope though that after a while
you know if i do this again and again
and again at the end
i wouldn't even have to ask the neural
network anymore sorry i wouldn't even
have to do search anymore during
inference is that something you
have you have you tried not even doing
search just using the neural network the
policy
uh output of the neural network during
inference is that something that
generally works because
you know i train it to predict
the output of the search so technically
let's say it should it should kind of
learn it no
uh yes the same the same way you simply
could just use say policy network in
alpha zero and let it play chess right
you you can do it and people have have
done it it still plays quite a
quite good chess but it's far far below
the the full strength of search so yes
yeah it at the end of the day even the
policy network is quite good but it's
not as good okay
yeah i mean it's it's just it it shows a
little bit that the search is in fact in
fact really necessary right
um yeah so i think we're we're almost
getting already to the sort of results
uh
wait would you would you maybe summarize
the results a little bit i think if
people are super interested they they
may go into uh into the paper and into
the tables but maybe you can just
summarize a little bit of the results
you you compare it against alpha zero in
perfect information games you compared
against
dedicated algorithms like like slumbot
in poker and you even compared against
like a dedicated ai for scotland yard
um what were generally the results for
you
so yes so
so in general the results are that the
algorithm is all about generality
which is
this is not as strong as alpha 0 in
perfect information games where alpha 0
was designed to shine right so this this
very much
is trying to be you general rather than
being the best chess or the best poke
poker poker agent in the world it's just
trying to be really really good in all
of them at once right so what is the
diff so if if a perfect information game
is just a special case of an imperfect
information game right what is then the
difference between player of games and
and alpha zero like why couldn't it
reach the same performance
so on on paper it could accept that will
for example the the policy improvement
algorithm that we use the counterfactual
minimization right it has to be also
good able to handle imperfect
information games that's why it's not
going to convert so nicely and quickly
as as algorithm designed to design for
perfect info so the the fact that you
expect sometimes to see an imperfect
information game
would it be fair would you estimate that
if you just input more resources input
more computation time that it would
actually reach the levels of alpha zero
i i i don't feel good necessarily i mean
on paper all of these would eventually
converge right but everything works on
paper in english
in practice alpha zero so and mct is
mcts is probably always going to be
ahead but we don't really care
right like
if
i would be happy with a single algorithm
for everything that's that's better in
humans yeah i don't care if it's better
by like a little bit or by a billion uh
yeah
and then in in um in poker here
you compared against slumbo which is you
say that the best open source or best
available
uh poker bot to date and this is no
limit poker now right this is this is
way too big of a game to solve and i
think the other ones
is
you uh you simply compare to the numbers
from their papers
is that
do you mean though for us
or for scotland well are we still
talking about poker oh sorry yeah let's
let's talk about poker for a while so
the the the player of games here gains
what is this seven
really big blinds per per hand yeah over
slumbot oh yeah again like we we we we
could have beaten slumber by by a lot
more yeah so like decided oh this is
good enough to like to put into a paper
we can come back to it later like
as you know it it very much depends on
how much time you spend to tune into the
network architecture and how for how
long to train this is what this is just
to show hey there's already an algorithm
that can do all of these games and it
still plays them really really well yeah
and
your neural network just to say it's a
bunch of like feed forward layers
correct like it's not a complicated
thing
so for poker it yeah for poco it's just
a feed forward network for chess and go
we do we try to mirror some of the older
alpha zero architectures
yeah
okay so and here on the right side you
have uh pimbot which is
uh these a scotland yard specific but
for people maybe people don't does
anyone not know what scotland yard is um
maybe you can describe 10 seconds what
scotland yard even is as a game it's
somewhere right yeah there's a figure
maybe right there is this figure right
right
yeah i yeah there's no point explaining
the rules in detail but on a high level
uh
there's a graph you you are trying to
chase down the uh chase down a stone
that's called mr x you have five
detectives that are trying to to to
chase to chase the stone down the trick
is the the the the stone the mr x that
you are trying to
chase down is only partially observable
that's what makes it imperfect
information and you have to basically
reason about states where where he could
be hiding and form some beliefs about
his state and trying to chase him down
so yeah and and
yeah i guess that's all people people
need to know you you can spend like
funny tickets on taxi rides and and uh
and uh
various tr methods of transport and then
every
every 10 turns or so mr x has to reveal
their position and that's how you sort
of form a belief about where mr x could
be given what actions mr mr x took so
this is quite a specific
game so it seems it seemed to me like a
dedicated
algorithm
could do very very well
uh again in in this game because it
could exploit various aspects of the
game you could hard code in you know
various various things the ai could
abuse um and here we see a graph of the
win rate of player of games against what
what's on the x-axis here this is number
of search iterations so pinboard is a
local search algorithm as well
yes it's it's a it's uh it's a wind of
mcts and this is to show regardless how
much time or search we give for the mcts
the hard code hand tune algorithm
even if it gets like a billion or
something for search iterations it's
still behind alpha zero because it's
using this general self-play learning
method
yeah so this is this would be i guess
the final win rate is here like at 55 or
something like this and that is with a
huge number of of iterations for for pim
bot
yes and we'll play our games is using
only like 400 iterations on our site so
yeah as you can see as you can see the
regardless of the scale we we convert to
a battery policy
and you do you would attribute that to
the use of self-play uh to improve the
strategies
it's the it's a combination of this and
also the fact that player of games is
built on some on sound methods like
later in the open appendix if people are
curious they can
open an appendix we show that on small
games where we can exactly measure how
close to an optimal policy the the
our resulting search policy is we get
closer and closer as as the times go so
basically we are only limited by by the
power of of neural networks and that we
have some guarantees that we we can get
to an optimal policy
other methods that are based on mcts
they they are not guaranteed to converge
even on small games
so there's there's there's there's also
the limit of the of the fact that these
methods are not sound
and just to get an idea of the scale of
like we saw you know poker uh uh
scotland yard here we have the the
chess and go and so on
can you give us a number of just how
many how many
gp tp whatever use do i need to run for
how long to get anywhere close to what
you did
i see so i think the
easiest tool for us
was poker
that like people probably can train on a
few few gpus
uh the the by far the hardest is is go
where we've used a lot of a lot of gpus
but it was simply because we we had them
available
yeah
i get okay and you you did in the paper
say that for comparison reasons you use
sort of the same amount of compute as
alpha zero did as well yeah that was uh
that was tricky right like it's like
because we do not
want to claim that this is uh this is
now state-of-the-art chess agent and
like they're there we don't have to do
all the proper and hard measurements
right then you have to use cloth time
and suddenly if you use cloth time you
have to argue that use the same hardware
and and everything gets gets more tricky
in here we just say well we use the we
call the network as as often as alpha
zero date so it should be roughly the
same but like we don't claim to be
stronger okay i mean that's a i think
community appreciates sort of fair
comparison instead of every every paper
having the new best state of the art
especially in rl like it seems it seems
clear just from the graphs here like
just from the lines it seems clear you
can just in invest more compute and get
better and that's what we also saw with
alpha zero like it used to be slightly
superhuman and now it's like you know no
human no like not all humans together
even will ever match
alpha zero in in any of these games
which is crazy yeah you would not win a
single game out of a thousand yeah
exactly um
you you have a bit of a demonstration
already you told me of uh
of of
uh the player of games playing scotland
yard
so we can kind of see what's going on
yeah let me see if it's still uh still
working it was working this morning it
was we we never planned to show it
externally we it was designed for our
debugging purposes but it would be a fun
demo just so that people who are not
familiar with scotland the art maybe you
get some intuition about the the game
okay so
the data hopefully you can see this yeah
and the let me very quickly explain what
is what this is about i am now playing
as mr x which is this black color in
here and i can move all i know all
on on this graph basically work work in
the edges and as you were talking about
those taxis and cubes you can see that
the edges have different colors so all
of these are yellow but this this guy is
blue and they correspond to two
different meaning of transportation that
i get to use say yellow stands for taxi
taxi i think and blue stands for bus
now detectives do not get to see where i
am but they do get to see which color
color did i use so right now i'm in here
and i say i want to go to 49 and i want
to use taxi together so yeah hopefully
like we have been talking for a while so
maybe
maybe it's not
a life
anymore
but uh yeah probably probably to
eat the diet
scale to zero
proper engineering
nice
yes so yeah
it doesn't work right now but uh at
least people can get an idea of what
would happen maybe
yeah so you you need to you need to
pretty quickly kind of reason
and the longer you don't see mr x the
more
sort of fuzzy your idea gets of where
mr
x is do you
do you visualize sort of this
distribution the belief distribution of
where mr x is or for debugging
uh we did it's i don't think it's it's
turned on right now but it's exactly
what we try to do at some at some point
yeah and did you see did you observe
this that's the longer they didn't see
mr x the more kind of
spread out
the more unsure they become is that
something you can clearly observe or is
that something you just feel as a human
oh yes and it it was actually really
really fun to to see
yes
crazy
and
so
the one uh improvement let's say or one
follow-up to alpha zero
was the mu zero algorithm
which
the crucial difference is alpha zero you
need sort of the simulator you need to
be able to simulate a lot of games uh
internally you need to know what happens
when i do some action what your kind of
state results from that and mu0
alleviated this
by sort of going to the latent space
state and training everything in latent
space is this something i could do with
player of games
uh no but that's
that's arguably the limitation number
two i think the biggest
being
the biggest thing is right now the
uh the larger large beliefs believe
space but the sec second one is we
currently need the model of the
environment
and uh mu0 doesn't even even need it so
you can think of player games as running
behind the alpha zero alpha zero lineage
and trying to generalize things but we
are still behind in that regard
and maybe a more more conceptual
question here in these in this entire
game trees and so on you know
for example in scotland yard
i
don't know where mr x is but mr x's
movements are kind of deterministic
right mr if mr x uses a taxi to get from
49 to 48
mr x is now at 48. however in poker for
example if i
bet something there will and my opponent
calls the flop will reveal like random
cards
how does this and this is different from
me not knowing what my opponent's cards
are right it's it's sort of pure
randomness within the game
is that something that makes things very
complicated or is the complicated part
like how do you deal with stochasticity
and with randomness in games which is
also something that doesn't exist in
chess that that part is actually quite
easy it's simply baked in into a into a
model and that's that's pretty much it
okay so you can you can sort of
condition on previous information and
the model will compute whatever expected
value
of of any future cards that could be
drawn in like flop and turn and river
you can think of it as basically having
you you just draw the surgery at the
beginning and simply one of those notes
you can think of as uh as some chance
actor playing and you have simply a
fixed policy in that note and a lot of
lot of actions that's it so when you
expand the search tree do you need to
expand
once for every possible let's say flop
combination there is yes
okay that that is a lot of combinations
right
or you can or you can substitute uh like
if you are smart about it you you can
again it's in your network there yeah
okay do you do you think humans because
in in alpha zero you can sort of think
that you do the same internally right
you kind of you kind of think ahead and
you until some depth and you say ah okay
here i guess and a little bit do you
think
player of games or in general these the
these algorithms with the imperfect
information is also a little bit like
like humans do it it seems vague that i
i go and i kind of go through all the
different flop combinations there could
be
um
or do you do you think there is a
fundamental difference between how
humans tackle these problems and how how
these algorithms do
i would so i would say
we would both agree that in scotland the
art you probably do the same right yeah
like looking forward like what if i go
here what if the opponent goes there and
then you you you do this like search
forward as you are thinking about the
beliefs of the opponent
yeah so in scotland i would say yes in
poker it it it's simply complicated by
the fact that suddenly the belief space
is big even like for humans even
thousands is probably too much
and
yeah i do like probably humans use some
light gender representation
there already i i don't know
cool and what is next in this line i
mean now you've you know you've built
like a big unifying algorithm that can
tackle any sort of game as long as it
like has a simulator
and and you said it's probably not
possible to go without a simulator so
what's next like it seems like you know
you've achieved kind of unification
where do you go from here
i think the most natural path is to
remove the constraints that that we just
discussed right it's going to fall apart
if there's a big uh belief space
and it still needs a model i and i think
this is something we probably want to
play with uh play with next like yeah
like
we like making algorithms that are truly
general i think
is a big step in this direction but it's
not to say that we are finished
and is so do you think if this line of
work continues it would be an algorithm
that
at some point could be thrown at pretty
much any problem
like atari and uh
like but even beyond reinforcement
learning right uh question answering uh
visual classification what not or even
robots and so on or do you think that is
kind of
a very different line of work
i i mean i did use
i did work on question and spherical
generation
[Music]
sorry so so on higher level this this is
certainly the dream right like not not
just of of of the team we work on this
but quite a few smart people in deep
mind like try to make something that's
true literally generally you don't
really care well the algorithm doesn't
really care whatever what environment
you throw it into you just like throw it
there and say okay alert so that's
that's rude that's the direction we are
going if player games can work all the
way there or if some of the ideas will
be simply used in other approaches we
shall see
cool
excellent well
in this case martin schmidt thank you so
much for being here uh this this was way
way i promised to everyone this was way
better if than if i had done this uh
myself so thanks a lot for for joining
us uh this was really awesome thank you
for having me this was fun thanks